hay sol capital del estado fronterizo de
mizoram en línea el sótano de este
edificio si todo en el valle sirve desde
hace poco como refugio para estos
hombres el hombre con la camisa blanca
que llamaremos moho por su seguridad
comparte aquí con otra decena de
personas raciones limitadas de alimentos
camino tres días y tres noches para
cruzar la frontera entre india mar y
tuvo que dejar atrás a su familia no era
policía ni al marq ahora vive escondido
lejos de sus seres queridos
y nuestros superiores nos dieron la
orden de dispararle a los civiles
personas inocentes que solo se estaban
manifestando no podíamos obedecer algo
así
entonces decidimos irnos de nuestro país
para proteger a nuestros conciudadanos y
salvar en nuestra propia vida
al igual que muchos policías abandonaron
su cargo y se refugiaron en el noroeste
de india ahora también por la seguridad
de sus familias que se quedaron en mí al
mar porque se negaron a obedecer las
órdenes de la junta militar
la situación no hacía más que empeorar
no tuve otra opción ahora estoy tratando
de que aquí debemos lograr instalarlos
aquí porque no estamos seguros en una
mano para delgado ya que lo como
modificador
en esta región de india la población es
solidaria con los refugiados de mianmar
ambos pueblos pertenecen a la misma
etnia emisora ban comparte 404
kilómetros de fronteras con los chinos
en mi amar con un acuerdo ya en esa
época muchos de nuestros hermanos y
hermanas chino llegaron de las colinas
priman us para refugiarse aquí y
nosotros los recibimos con los brazos
abiertos nos volvimos amigos ahí vamos
juntos a la escuela éramos como una
misma familia
los gal fue testigo de otra ola de
refugiados de mi alma durante los años
80 como la junta militar ya había tomado
el poder
si no los ayudamos quién lo hará es
nuestro deber porque se trata de
nuestros hermanos y hermanas a unos
kilómetros de aquí más cerca de la
frontera alrededor de 1.000 refugiados
están instalados desde hace un mes en
esta pequeña ciudad
una ong local dirigida por peter shan
que les ayuda
los refugiados llegaron a mizoram sin
dinero comida ni refugio ni siquiera
tenían ropa para cambiarse entonces
nuestra organización les da esas cosas
esenciales un alojamiento camas comidas
hacemos lo que más poder para los
habitantes locales han donado productos
esenciales que peter chan de
redistribuye son cosas esenciales que
nuestros hermanos y hermanas necesitan
en el campamento donde viven pero
queremos mantener la ubicación del lugar
en secreto por su seguridad
entonces les entregamos todo aquí
el gobierno central indio y el estado de
mizoram están en desacuerdo sobre la
gestión de las poblaciones que huyen de
mianmar
el mes pasado el partido del gobierno el
pj pe le pidió a las autoridades de la
región fronteriza que pidieran toda
entrada ilegal al territorio y que
identificara a los migrantes en cuestión
para deportarlos por el partido en el
poder en mizoram se opone
order y happy feet
y no estamos de acuerdo con las
instrucciones del ministerio del
interior que nos pide que no dejemos
entrar a esas personas que las enviamos
de regreso a su país
somos solidarios y apoyamos a quienes
cruzaron la frontera para demorarse aquí
queremos protegerlos y darles los
recursos que necesitan vanities 'no
protección para el riesgo de deportación
pesa como la espada de damocles sabe que
un regreso a mianmar es sinónimo de pena
de muerte
mi mayor temor es que nos impidan vivir
aquí y que nos envíen de regreso a mi el
mar
mientras la junta militar se aferra más
que nunca al poder en mianmar moi
nosotros miles de refugiados esperan que
india aceptó oficialmente protegerlos